we have not spoken about oan for a while
oan is one American news or sometimes
it's o-a-n-n one American News network
oan is sort of the crazy uncle to
Newsmax which is already like the crazy
uncle to Fox News Fox News is hard right
wing propaganda Newsmax is Extreme right
wing propaganda and oan would sort of be
like something even more insane I don't
even know what it's crazier than Newsmax
with even worse production value and
anchors who struggle even more obviously
to read the teleprompter I want to call
your attention to a segment that aired
yesterday on oan this is a blend of
globalist One World Government
conspiracy theories combined with
straight up lies about how things work
in the real world
the anti-vaccine absurdity has reached a
new level on oan and in this clip we're
going to hear from an anchor named
Christina Bob that's Bob with two B's at
the end BLB
she was visibly struggling to read the
conspiracies off of the teleprompter the
whole segment but the case she makes is
that globalists global-ish as Alex Jones
would say are getting ready to scrap the
Nuremberg code in Europe in order to
make covid vaccines mandatory for all
now there are maybe anything one two
there's like six or seven layers of
dishonesty and confusion in this segment
let's look at the video listen to the
video you'll notice that compared to
this drivel Newsmax almost seems
measured if you can believe it let's
take a look
covet is about control and manipulating
our physical bodies through the vaccine
which is one of the most humiliating and
inhumane ways to demoralize a person by
depriving them of control of their own
bodies and subjecting humans to Medical
experiments it's for that reason that
the World created the Nuremberg codes
after World War II we recognize that
medical experiments concentration camps
mass murder and all the other atrocities
that occurred during the war were
inhumane and should never be tolerated
again yet the European Union leadership
is now calling for throwing out the
Nuremberg code Ursula vanderley the head
of the European Union commission has
argued in favor of throwing out the
Nuremberg code ignore it completely and
allow countries to force vaccinate
anyone refusing to participate in the
medical experiment the globalists are
going crazy in resorting to Crazy
methodologies that most humans would not
agree with like ignoring the Nuremberg
code why because they are losing it is a
last resort to out themselves as the
evil inhumane tyrants that they are so I
mean listen let's just go line by line
right covet is about controlling other
people no it's not covet is a pandemic
and we're trying to get out of it safe
the vaccines manipulate our physical
bodies this is along the lines of they
change your DNA they don't that's not
true the vaccines are inhumane
there is no scientific basis for that
assertion the vaccines are a medical
experiment no they aren't they're
approved by emergency use authorization
and the Pfizer vaccine has full FDA
approval and then we get into like the
really wacky stuff the Nuremberg codes
were created to stop medical experiments
she says now that's true the Nuremberg
codes were created after World War II
and it does relate to human
experimentation it just has no relevance
to vaccines that have been approved at
all the European Union is not calling
for throwing out the Nuremberg code and
this is like the big lie
Ursula vanderlein is the head of the
European commission and she recently
said at a press conference the European
Union's member states should encourage
and they should think about making
vaccines mandatory not you have to make
them mandatory member states meaning
countries like Belgium France Etc they
should think about mandatory vaccination
she didn't mention the Nuremberg code
she said nothing about scrapping the
Nuremberg code she said nothing about
allowing medical experimentation
vaccination has nothing to do with
Nuremberg code this has nothing to do
with globalists or globalism this is not
anything to do with the new world order
or one world government or anything like
it but this is exactly how this stuff
spreads think about the chain
Ursula vanderlein says countries should
look at mandatory vaccination
it is then reported on falsely as she
sang Get rid of the Nuremberg code and
the next thing you know the EU wants to
re-legalize Nazi medical experiments it
is how it builds it's one layer of
propaganda built on another and another
and another have they no shame no they
have no shame but this is about
something much much worse and uh I don't
expect this to end anytime soon their
claim is the left ones to keep us in the
pandemic forever to control people
understand that it is them who in a way
benefit from the pandemic by being able
to get clicks by spreading this nonsense
day after day after day so don't fall
for it this is how it spreads and we're
gonna have more on this including uh
this clip on our Instagram I hope you
are following us there at davidpakman
show and you can also follow me on
Instagram at david.pakman we'll take a
quick break and we have plenty more
coming right up